okay
you got a problem here guy
Melissa I will come your way first I
said this to you the other day I love
how you establish a foundation for Sam
in screen five and then just run with it
here what is one thing you wanted to
keep consistent about the character from
five to six but then also what is
something that you wanted to show the
audience that's new to her now based on
how she responded to the events of five
um I think I I mean Sam is a tough girl
and I think I wanted that to continue
but I definitely wanted to show a more
vulnerable side of her in this one and
get to show more shades to her because
now that like the damn has bursts
there's just so much that naturally
would come out and that fear of like
having to protect your sister I think
would just give way to have a lot more
emotions come out and I think that's
what I was really excited to explore in
this next movie I can't and besides how
well that works here that complexity is
just on point and I love it Jennifer
you've obviously had your fair share of
horror experience not only does scream
in general now feel like a like a unique
franchise overall but this movie in
particular feels like a really unique
installment of it so is there anything
even with all that horror experience
that like caught you by surprise in
terms of what it took to make screamed
six in particular well I think
oftentimes in horror films I am just
screaming and crying I feel like I'm
often either really annoying or I play
the stupid character and tear this time
around out of Personality which was
interesting to kind of play with and
then also the Change of Atmosphere I
think because scream has never left
Woodsboro before I felt like it made it
a lot more intimidating and it kind of
gave us more room to kind of play or
isolated our main cast in a way that
we've never seen in a screen film before
so I think that there was a really
interesting Dynamic that automatically
came with that and um kind of something
a bit more horrific and
um kind of grounding in a way very
successful with that here I will say
they're screaming and crying in X but
she makes choices and she she has has
her own personal drive there she's cool
for a second and then she goes back on
it she just becomes really judgmental
and gross I mean like that I get it all
right Courtney you're getting a very
specific question from me because it was
emphasized quite a few times in screen
five that Gail was not going to write
another book she writes another book and
we don't see her make that choice
because it happens in between the events
of the two films in your mind why does
she make that choice is there a specific
life event that kind of turned her on
that path again I think she loves Fame
she loves to be recognized and thought
of and as she says somebody was going to
do it and why not why wouldn't she get
the credit she knows the story there's
another very specific question because
there is the lightest mention in the
movie that Gail also didn't have the
best relationship with her parents and
I'm surprised over the years I haven't
thought about this but is there any
backstory work you've done over the
years to determine like why Gail is the
person she is and why she's gone on this
particular career path I mean I would
definitely say well I mean that's what
usually happens isn't it where your
family you've been neglected or you have
we all have so many triggers in life and
I think that
um she had many for all three of you now
at what point in the making of this
movie did you learn who the killer was
um I'm reading the script yeah I think I
mean I remember specifically Matt and
Tyler withholding the third Act of the
script when they sent it to us to read
and it wasn't until I think we were
about to start shooting that they
actually gave us the last act yeah right
what I what I will say is it was
interesting once you knew who Ghostface
was watching them set up their play
because you know they would say a line a
certain way yeah or give you a certain
look and you'd think uh I'm on to you I
agree I love that I did not know who the
killer was gonna be
because once Gail dies or lives whatever
one she left I love not knowing and I
loved watching the actors going wait a
minute are you a good actor are you a
good actor acting like you're acting
Courtney is so funny because we'd be on
set and she was like I didn't read the
script I just read my parts
until I die or not in it anymore but she
plays the game behind the scenes she's
like I'm gonna figure it out because and
yeah you figured it out yeah she was
right I'm not surprised but also you get
to watch the actors perform so like you
said it's that's my favorite part
I I can't wait to watch it again so I
can see all of these little performance
like beats and subtleties that I missed
the first time around yeah you also get
your very first ghost face haul even
having watched other cast members do you
know like heavy action attack set pieces
involving a call is there anything about
the production process of shooting a
scene like that that surprised you
um not surprising it was just uh it was
a lot of work I mean we'd go in on not
when we were filming and rehearse the
fight scene and you know it's it's also
let me tell you you can carry a rubber
pan but if I hit him I would have
actually hurt him or you know he's using
a knife and coming after me it's not
like retractable it actually was so I'm
just glad he didn't hurt me let me
actually call me that sequence might be
one of the most tense sequences of the
entire franchise for me and I think I
think it's because the choreography is
spectacular but also because that is a
scene that highlights the emotional
investment that this franchise has
earned from fans over the years so
congratulations on that for fun because
clearly I'm scream obsessed but I'm also
a New Yorker and I love being here so
I'm going to set a little scene for you
you as in real you you're in New York go
space is on the loose and he's looking
for you and he's going to kill you in
your favorite place in Manhattan where
is he gonna kill you because I die in
The Meatball Shop I die in a Broadway
Theater
I go
I feel like I might die in a theater as
well I don't know if I have a specific
one but a good show is yeah I think um
maybe Elio's Uptown where there's a lot
of people and like you wouldn't expect
it
okay so no one would know and they're so
crowded there you just I fall over and
I'll be it if you had the opportunity to
take home one item from the shrine which
one would you pick and why uh either the
Casey Becker rope
uh or the Tatum garage door I don't know
where I'm gonna put that or what I'm
gonna do with that but the fact that I
saw that in the yeah that was insane to
see that was a good one I think there's
a there was a really cool phone the
melted phone the melted oh it's the fax
machine yeah
I'm taking Stu's TV because Stu is dead
I don't tolerate that theory he is dead
he's dead oh oh you don't like that he's
alive honestly
there we go they think that Steve is
still alive who does people oh I think
so yeah I don't think so either
you say it it speaks it into existence
everyone must stop now Stu is dead guys
foreign
first thing that I remembered from
Scream five is that you reached out to
Jamie and you had a little interaction
have you two met or conversed more about
your character sins we've messaged a bit
more but we haven't met yet in person I
think he invited me to be on his podcast
which doesn't really hasn't happened but
um I I would love to meet him in person
and for him to continue to tell me I'm
amazing did he have any hot takes on
Mindy he said that he liked her he said
that he um he appreciated what I did and
that felt really good no he hated
Mason's prayer most people do that's
okay I like that they have the
wherewithal to tell me that though
honesty here no but you would believe
that especially after you make my heart
explode in this movie
really sweet I mean it I mean it
um speaking of Randy for a minute so
with the rules here do you have a
favorite new rule in this movie given
the fact that now it's set in a big city
but also given the recoil sequel
franchise rules right do you remember
Mindy's rules I like the I I think this
is the second time you said bigger
budget because you mentioned beheadings
oh yeah that's just wasn't that line
changed uh no beheadings are still in
there it is it is okay you can confirm
it is there's a nice nod to it too
really and truly I I like that that was
a very organic moment we were saying oh
beheadings that's that's the guy really
grisly yeah I can't wait to see that pay
off and it did people find that one out
I enjoy that
um going back to something you are busy
talking about for the first film your
NYU paper I heard a little bit about the
paper but I I do I want to know what
your thesis was what what was the core
of the idea in terms of why the original
screen should be rebooted the well it
wasn't so much why so much the conceit
that scream as a franchise is right for
Revival simply because of the uh
Timeless aspect of referential uh Cinema
that in the post-modern landscape of
making movies you kind of can take films
that both reference themselves and the
genre at large and just update it each
and every time with new casts of
characters and also new killers and
motives that I don't necessarily think
assuming it's done writing with Karen
with passion and uh whatnot that it can
kind of strike gold each and every time
so long as it's uh capturing the
Zeitgeist it finds itself in it was
legit read that paper and probably enjoy
it if you ever shared it awesome man I
wrote it when I was like 20 yeah
donate it to charity uh that's actually
a brilliant idea I'm into that I think
I'll bid on it
um given what you just brought up about
the paper though since the release of
Scream 5 is there any new horror movie
that's been released that you would love
to see a scream 7 reference ah M3 again
oh and I want the sequel to be M forgan
Morgan I'm telling you I've written the
movie for you guys that's right let's
put her in M4 again I need Megan to
fight not and then I did play m4 again
and then if there's another scream and
Mindy mentioned it and I was talking
about myself
it's the first time I think I've ever
heard someone say that out loud I'm
freaking like I thought about it but I
don't think I've ever heard it I'm
Morgan Morgan I'm Morgan Morgan Freeman
um yeah you want you want and and all
you can do I can't even say it
uh Megan for sure I also think there's a
big market for like indie horror to like
really get the like horror fans involved
Megan is my real answer but if there was
like a reference to something subtle
like a Cannibal Holocaust or something
just really out there I would love
really going for it yeah man uh a
movie's tough yeah for so many reasons
there's definitely a lot that fall in
that department I don't know if I can
handle that version of a screen movie
you know well I just wouldn't want
people to watch and go I should check
out that movie because they'd be
traumatized yeah that's my Martyrs I
can't handle Martyrs really oh no one
messed me up for a little while there
you go see we all have those movies
though that when we're told like you
should check this out it'll mess you up
and you're like I can handle it yeah
mine for me it's what is it uh the one
after hereditary
um yeah because the scene where he's
jumped under his head really wrong
Midsummer was a great meditation on
breakups I bet you're gonna say it's a
great meditation like turn on to
meditate it was like you need help
shout out to Archie uh his character
died by getting his back filled and
filled with flowers and then I met him
and he's a great guy and he doesn't have
any flowers in his face or it's giving
yellow jackets
going back to scream now the shrine if
you could both keep one particular item
from that Shrine which one would you
pick and why you'd keep the camera I
changed my answer so what is it
um they have the Cheetos the bat like
the Vintage Cheetos
That's So Dope I love that I love when
uh movies callbacks I'd keep up I'd keep
uh some of the photos of Dewey all right
pizza the realest I'll never get over
that ever ever I know this is such a sad
that's true you could be alive he just
had his belly slit he I feel like Chad's
experienced something similar who knows
the thing that I think about all the
time is because like the item I would
keep is the TV and everybody out there
you guys make jokes about it everybody
out there loves to say Stu is live I say
stew is alive so I could meet Matthew
Lillard that's why I say I mean that's
fair love him so much I respect that
reasoning for it hi Matthew I love you
I love the core four so to to highlight
that kind of family Vibe can you each
tell me something about your character
that they get via the core for I know
broadly they all get the benefit of
family and support but how can you to
grow as individuals via the core for I
feel like uh Chad could certainly use
his sister's sense of style although
that being said I when I tell you I was
so excited for my wardrobe and scream
six I got to wear Converse and a hoodie
which I've always wanted to wear in any
form of media because that's so
authentic to what I would wear in that
setting the hoodie gave me cotton weary
Vibes and I liked that okay there you go
you get it I liked I liked that aspect
of it but if we're being real Mindy has
such
um
nasty drip and she I feel like if he
could maybe cop some of that I I think
he could help you out there and then
Chad could teach Mindy how to you know
like do some push-ups and pull-ups beef
up a bit exercise because Mindy could
not you know last in a fist fight
necessarily I mean we've seen that more
than once those quads those hamstrings
she goes out pretty easy
Sharon given she goes through here's
here's a good follow-up to that actually
because you get two pretty significant
set pieces where one is very action
heavy and one is mostly done through you
know tension building editing you as an
actor which one do you find more
difficult more difficult oh that's a
really good question
um they're difficult in different ways
the the the tension building is more
difficult because it is so Technical and
it's like okay we need you to look here
look here look here look here look here
but the other is difficult because it
takes like freaking days and by the last
day you're so tired I am at least Devin
wasn't but she's in her early 20s right
that's the discrepancy it's the yeah
bounce back so bad here's a here's a big
burning acting question I've had for
this entire franchise what what is the
key or what is a tip or trick you would
give to another actor for acting stabbed
acting stabbed and also how one must
feel after the stabbing has occurred
Melissa had a great comment on on like
she asked someone who's been stabbed and
they said like oh it feels really cold
and then where the knife moves
thereafter you'd have to imagine would
hit so many nerves that that's when the
pain would kick in
um I think it's like don't be afraid of
it looking too big and it's very
physical
right
that's so embarrassing I thought you
were stabbed I know
wow I'm gonna try to squeeze in one more
question here please I have a feeling
you have both been asked about this but
I could talk about this all day long do
you have an absolute favorite Ghost Face
Killer obviously not including screen
six oh great um easy I think Mikey
Madison I really freaking loved her
reveal every time I see that I scream
I'm like yeah so good because I am what
also like kind of hot yeah I'm gonna put
you on the spot if you had to pick a
ghost face from a movie that you are not
in Japan but Mikey is an excellent
choice and deserves loads of credit for
what she does
if not Mikey Mrs Loomis is 10 out of 10.
that's a power suit murdering mom he
loves a woman in a stop saying mommy
these days
what mommy's just like um a woman with a
stop now all I could think about the
fact that it's like people keep calling
Pedro Pascal daddy so now I need like
like Mommy and Daddy dude
that's true
he'd not come your way first to talk a
little bit about Kirby's Evolution here
what is one particular quality of hers
that you wanted to maintain from Scream
4 to now but then also what's something
you deliberately wanted to do different
to show how those events impacted her
um I wanted to keep her spunk her spunk
is is something I love her spunk her
curiosity her she's just a badass and
then what I what I wanted to change I
mean over the years is is I wanted her
to be the person that came out of the
trauma
fighting as a fighter swinging and
wanting the bad guys to be afraid of her
that's that's what I truly wanted and
they did not disappoint the more that
fight the better all right dermit for
you I know you have done horror movies
before but scream is a little bit of a
unique type of production process so
what would you say is the biggest
misconception you had about what it
would take to make a Scream movie going
into filming oh well I was so impressed
with this script I you know
um you know I got it in pieces so even
that was kind of a piecing it together
process which made it fun because then
the review was really its own experience
even for the reader but I knew I was
entering a world that had well it's even
right there in the screen in Scream they
tell you the rules of the movie then
they make the rules and then they break
the rules and they use them against you
and it's wonderful and I've loved it
throughout the films I studied them all
and I watched them leading up to
beginning work on screen six so um by
then
uh yeah I mean I just seen scream five
and like the next day I'm shooting
Scream Six so it was that close together
the filmmakers made these films so
quickly close together that it's almost
like a double package um I just thrilled
to join this cast um that did so well
and and made a hit movie on screen five
that's one of the most impressive
elements of the film I can't believe how
good it is and how short a period of
time they had to turn it around it's
mind-blowing really and we had
production issues as well as everyone
during that period um did making movies
and so we fought through that everybody
showed up with uh all of um incredible
energy in the final scenes of course
where most of the characters are in the
same place it's just almost like a play
which
ever done but you know what I mean it'd
be like if we're in a theater we're in a
green room together all a very small
room yeah no it was very much like a
play and I have done one really close
they welcomed me into so it was amazing
you fit right in ah great great all
right speaking of that cast I absolutely
love asking about the value of a good
scene partner so can each of you name a
time on this set when a scene partner
gave you just what you needed in a
challenging moment and it helped you
reach something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
without them oh
um I would definitely say I mean I would
say Dermot well we had this wonderful
scene too yeah police station great
scenes uh together
um and and thank you for that no but
it's it's it's true I'm actually you
know thank you for that tape because of
course not only are you in the scene the
one that knows more about the ghost face
you're also the actor in the scene that
knows more about Scream movies so your
presence and your experience I'm
thanking you for it made a difference
for me yeah in being able to portray
that scene even more honestly because
that was part of our real truth just uh
yeah Pro and and Jasmine boy Brown
obviously in that scene that we that we
had when we go had to head she she
brought it and she's just she is a love
and and just such a light and
um and working with her it was amazing
everyone's incredible but those who
really stand out and to discreetly
answer that question I was very
impressed by Melissa's um
athleticism oh yeah that girl that
really brought a lot in that way the
whole cast is required of yourself
included but um
um yeah there are moments in the film
where that came into play with with
certain characters this might be a tough
question to answer without teetering
spoilers waiting on that last question
with with Melissa I feel like she has
one of the greatest challenges and winds
up being one of the biggest wild cards
in terms of like balancing genuinely
want to protect the people that she
loves but also tapping into that Billy
Loomis blood lust so can you each name a
time where maybe she took something that
was on the page and she did something
way different than you ever could have
imagined with it I never imagined
anything I don't come with expectations
so I was always
um surprised I was always surprised but
she she's such a warm loving Spirit
um so to see her ever go
dark or have an ominous moment takes you
back yeah
she's look in her eyes she certainly
does um if you're saying that Melissa
get to look in your eye
um that but yeah again it's hard to
answer I I will say when I saw the film
I was so impressed by everybody's it's
like it's hard to think that in Scream
there would be any subtlety no that's
what the leads are using in there if you
if you don't know what it is and why it
seems so funny when it's underplayed
Melissa Jenna too they they really hit
that tone in such a satisfying way in
other words scream is kind of
you know it's gotten more and more
intimate in some of it I don't know used
to be a little broader now it's the
realer environment between special teams
between the sisters and that storyline
um so they made it so real the love some
of it you know as an actor they can make
it so small and it still fits on a
really big stage so I'm so impressed as
a die-hard fan I appreciate that because
you have to evolve the Francis and I
feel like that's one particular way that
they are making these new movies feel
incredibly different it works can I add
that you know if the broader
conversation is how acting Styles have
changed and maybe become more subtle or
just a little different since 96 to now
25 years of acting you know
style it is definitely a different game
now than it was when we started okay
speaking of that style a little and this
is not a spoiler it is a rule of scream
everybody is a suspect yeah for maybe a
future actor who's going to join the
scream franchise what tip or trick would
you give them in terms of presenting
their character as though they could be
a suspect but also not going too far in
that respect pick your moments just pick
your choose your moments yeah wisely
those moments where you could throw
somebody off yeah I'm tapping into a
sensation of my own brain saying don't
do anything
yeah don't don't even some of those
frames are filled with eight and ten
people right also and you know well from
experience that certain types of
movements or if you're further back or
if there's a lighting thing that you
flash you know the human eye goes I
think so it's just something
all of the actors are calculating what
their character would do how they would
then their behavior would reflect their
character but the time screen move you
also have to be really careful
Stillness and the and the I mean even
just a blank even just a lack of a blank
breath and and that moment I learned a
lot from these guys from the scream cast
it's right away I got the sense that
it's not as broad as it used to be as
someone who has a Keen Eye for all those
details you nailed all the right things
on that list there I am a New Yorker in
addition to being a Die Hard scream fan
so I need to celebrate the location in
this movie so I'm going to throw you
into a scenario real you you're out and
about New York and go space is somewhere
in New York where does go space manage
to find and kill you what is your
favorite place in New York that they
know they can find you for example I
will die in The Meatball Shop
where's that Meatball Shop it is not far
from where we are right now and it is
excellent for meatballs you can make a
movie about that horrified
an Italian restaurant oh oh actually no
um what's the oh my mom would you know
this uh there's there's a a
um a restaurant that's about
um it's dead people like like like they
it's Frankenstein basically comes down
and it's this whole show so you have a
horrible
it's this restaurant that used to be my
favorite my favorite
I don't remember what it was yeah that's
brilliant see it's like a it's a show
within a show within a show but then
yeah I like it mine would be Central
Park super cinematic okay
can happen in New York that's right
amazing